hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you how I made about a mill uh
while I was sleeping I just left the
offers in overnight in the morning I
sold them very quickly and made about a
mill in profit 950k to a mill anyway and
uh pretty easy to do you're going to
need about 10 to 30 mil and uh just a
grand exchange all right let's get
started all right guys we're about ready
to go what you're going to need for this
method is between 10 and 30 mil and and
uh that's pretty much it you won't need
any requirements cuz what we're going to
be doing today is creating page sets so
we're going to be buying a each piece of
the page so armad page 1 2 3 and four
and then we're going to combine them
into the book of law or something like
that uh so to start off here I found two
sets that will net us probably between
80 and 100K uh per set that we combine
that is the Unholy book and the armal
page uh the book of law sorry uh so
we'll do one quick calculation for you
just so you know how to do it all you're
going to do is take the price that the
page set is selling for so for in this
case it's about
2375 and then we're start sub uh
subtracting all the page costs off so
zamra page one is selling for
about
minus
minus 535 roughly
oops and finally uh the last page shows
for about
460 all right that leaves us with
roughly 100K in profit uh so yeah we'll
go ahead and buy the pieces and see if
we actually get that much all right so
zamra page one we're going to buy for
about 490 zamak page one
uh we'll do
492k and now I believe the limit for
these is five uh so we're just going to
do five pages at a time uh zamak page
two is going for about
785 yeah we'll do it for 75 Z page
75 and we'll do five of those as
well next up Samar page three
[Music]
the zamak page 3 is hopefully going for
about 540 uh we're not quite sure if
we'll get that or not but yeah we'll do
540 541 and we're going to do five of
those as
well and last up is the zamak page
4 which seems to be going for about
so
462 and put in five so we start with 30
mil that is used about 12 mil now the
second page that we're going to do is
the armal one and it is ning us
about 80k roughly uh which is still
pretty good considering it's also much
cheaper for the set we'll go ahead and
buy that as well armal page one we're
going to go for about
230k
armad page
two is going for
about
400k maybe
yeah
403k
sure and the armal page
three is going for about 366 now that's
a decent difference between the buy and
sell price uh so that's good 367 we'll
go for and five of
those and last up here armor little page
four is going for
about
427 428 sure all right that's it guys so
we have all our offers in uh you can see
a couple of them are coming through so
these pages honestly don't take that
long to buy uh but you do have to wait a
while so I recommend doing this before
you get to bed uh overnight is the best
time to buy stuff like this I've done
this a couple times and almost every
time I wake up all the pages have boten
you could even do 10 of each page
overnight uh cuz you you'd hit the bind
limit but I might have enough time to
buy all 10 anyway we'll come back when
these a bot combine the pages and see
how much money we make all right guys
we're back and we bought most of the
items pretty smoothly unfortunately just
for the armal page 2 and Zam page 4 we
did have to increase the price by a
little bit uh we had to increase the
page four just by 1K so not a big deal
uh the Aral page twos we did have to
increase by almost 10K uh such just 20K
we're cutting out of our profits uh but
not a huge deal all right so we're going
to go ahead and collect all the
pages boom so now we have five of every
single page and the easiest part of this
is just going to the Grand exchange
clerk go into
set and then at the bottom there should
just be the page sets pack the page set
for armadel and pack the page set for
zamra and now you have five Unholy book
page sets and five law page sets I
should mention that this can work with
all the pages these were just the most
profitable at the time um but I would go
ahead and have a look at all of them
okay so now all we're going to do is
just find a rough sell price for them so
for the zamra uh or Unholy book page set
sorry and uh we're going to sell it for
about
so
K and all five were sell them for about
11.9 mil not too bad and the armad
ones and the Book of law page sets open
to sell for about
1538 15
38k
and we're selling those for about 7.7
mil all right guys we'll come back when
they sold and we'll actually tally up
how much we made all right guys we're
back and almost everything is sold now
we've been stuck on this one Unholy book
set for like an hour now so I think we
got undercut on it so we'll probably
just end up dumping it uh but we'll
collect everything and see how much
money uh we would have made and then
we'll just dump it and see what we
actually end up with uh so we have 28
mil and we have one Unholy book page Set
uh so we take that into account take
that
out and I guess we just price check it
in our price checker let's just see what
the uh OS buddy price is saying about
30990 so we made about 1 milon profit
off of these items which is extremely
good uh again there's not a huge risk
involved here the pag is probably bought
in an hour or two overnight uh the uh
pretty much all the book sets sold uh
they don't actually take that long just
clear like a undercut a bit uh so we'll
go ahead and just dump the book set and
just see what we get
it and
uh okay [__]
it sold it for
2297 yeah that's a little bit weak but
either way uh we're going to end with
over 900k in profit 95k would have
easily been around 9990k but uh I'm
working full-time it's busy I got to get
out of here so we got to finish this
video up so anyway I hope you guys got
the point and enjoyed the video still
and uh I'll see you guys in the next one
bye
[Music]
guys